donc ça c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi un
problème là dessus puisque il ya des
milliers d'ici un des établissements
privés hors contrat candidats libres ou
encore les bts qui on est obligé de
passer lors d'épreuves en présentiel
tandis que la grande majorité des
étudiants bénéficieront du contrôle
continu tout le monde jusque chez une
situation injuste
un deux poids deux mesures qui est
dénoncé par les étudiants comme par les
parents qui se demandent pourquoi on
tient pas compte de la crise sanitaire
pour certains et pas pour d'autres
alors on va en parler bien sûr avec
claudia qui étudiante en bts claudia
comment ça va déjà ça va ôter alors
qu'est ce qui se passe vous êtes vous
êtes colère complètement pourquoi qu'est
ce qui se passe est en bts qui s'est
passé optique oui en deuxième année
bah vous allez pouvoir vous occupez de
castaldi j'ai donc dû coucher en bts
optique chez actuellement en deuxième
année et je passe mes épreuves la
semaine du 10 mai donc mes épreuves
commencent lundi
sachant que j'ai déjà eu en orale en
écrit d'anglais le lendemain du nouveau
confinement
j'étais en salle d'examen avec des
milliers d'élèves sans restriction en ce
sens mais sur cet ensemble sur sa
distance ac s'est longtemps pour moi
pardon mais bien sûr on n'était pas
protégé on subit constamment
l'impression on sait pas de quoi va être
fait nos examens
il nous parle d'un rattrapage sans
forcément donner de détails en fait on
ne sait pas où on va on sait pas où est
ce qu'on va on sait pas ce qu'on fait on
on bosse on révise mais c'est tout ce
qu'on sait tous qu'on peut faire on n'a
aucune réponse à nos questions vous êtes
un cas alors j'espère qu'on va voir des
réponses dans un instant je prône
d'abord vos témoignages
il ya et il y aussi eddy qu'habite
grenoble élève en terminale spécialité
géopolitique et littérature anglaise on
allait de même passion et alors vous
c'est quoi le problème
bah le problème c'est que dans un mois
et demi on a des épreuves de bac n'a le
grand oral le bijou de la réforme de la
réforme bancaire et que bat pour la
littérature anglaise
j'ai pas de questions j'ai pas de
problématique pour le grand oral est en
fait tout ça ça vient parce que
on a eu un manque de préparation j'ai eu
ma professeur qui a été absente tout ça
en plus on a des propos des programmes
qui sont surchargés ma professeur quand
elle est revenue elle a fait tout ce
qu'elle a pu vraiment pour pour nous
aider mais actuellement
moi je suis en incapacité de me
présenter aux cantonales sereinement
tout simplement parce que je suis pas
prêt quand vous avez peur de l'avenir
j'ai surtout peur du grand oral donc
dans la main et demi enfin bien sûr
parce que alors on a on avait le vine
aussi qui est avec nous 18 ans il habite
à gisors élèves en bac pro transport toi
alors babel wien temps grève de la faim
je suis j'ai commencé une grève de la
faim depuis ce matin mon lit ça va pour
l'instant juste le ramadan jours pour
l'instant t c'est ça va tu étais était
bien l'auteur aussi bien on a commencé
ce matin voilà j'ai mené plusieurs
exactions pourquoi tu mets d'une grève
de la faim je mène une grève de la faim
parce que j'ai fait une première vidéo
que j'ai partagé sur les réseaux pour
interpeller à monsieur emmanuel macron
ainsi que monsieur jean michel blanquer
on n'a pas eu de réponse j'ai dit c'est
quoi votre vidéo elle dénonce et que
tout simplement les conditions dans
laquelle nous battre au on est par
exemple dans mon lycée
le deux jours trois jours a été mis en
place donc deux jours en présence et à 3
juin distant ciel les les battrons pour
la plupart ont pas le droit c'est à dire
on est à 100% de la semaine en cours est
à 100% on et 13 dans nos classes et ont
des fois à une trentaine pour thaon et
manger transport ga nature et c2c des
conditions inadmissibles
ça me fait doucement rire quand monsieur
monsieur blanc caire parle de 2012 parce
que l'ado messieurs jean pro pour
l'instant la connais pas du tout donc on
est en danger toute la semaine et les
vidéos à cette vidéo avait pour but de
comme j'ai dit dans la vidéo de tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé
tant qu'à notre situation et donc j'ai
fait une deuxième vidéo
alors vous allez dire tout ça
anne-christine langue qui va être avec
nous c'est d'ailleurs on dit que c'est
la ministre bis de l'éducation du mollet
tout est question va pouvoir nous donner
des réponses et peut-être des solutions
qui lui dire tout ça qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous de ce qu'ils lisent déjà
là est ce que vous comprenez leur
situation est ce qu'on vous dit non
c'est un caprice la situation elle est
profondément injuste pour plein
d'étudiants fossard qui a plein
d'étudiants qui réclament les examens en
contrôle continu ils veulent pas faire
les examens en présentiel pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont eu des cours de manière très
irrégulière cette année et que les
examens en présentiel on va pas se
mentir ils ont de fortes
lens de louper leur examen donc de
redoubler donc je pense avoir ajouté
encore une tannée alors année qui est
déjà au rip sicot logiquement mais
franchement si l'état pouvait faire un
effort et éviter à ses étudiants de
sombrer encore plus dans la dépression
en plus ça a coûté énormément d'argent à
tout le monde ses redoublements donc
qu'ils fassent un état à un effort xwave
selon un sondage est à 91 % des lycéens
qui souhaitent passer le bac en contrôle
continu donc ça fait très bien partie
très peu en amont à louis brouillard lui
qui vient souvent nous voir porte parole
du mouvement de solidarité étudiante
louis site avec toi une une demande à
formuler au ministre l'éducation
d'ailleurs tu auras une représentante de
l'éducation dans un instant tu dirais
quoi parce que toi tu es très énervé je
lui dirais de venir dans une salle de
classe
en fait dans toutes les salles de classe
de france parce que quand quand on veut
comprendre le sujet comme tu le dis il
ya les lycées publics les lycées privés
les statures alex ned il ya les lycées
il ya les collèges et en fait on a mille
et une situation qui ont dû être gérées
différemment
c'est bête mais pour un bts qui doit par
exemple faire de l'esthétique ou un
autre qui doit faire du bâtiment
certains n'ont juste pas pu le faire il
ya eu les professeurs absents le
matériel informatique a pas fonctionné
et pendant toute cette crise sanitaire
tout le monde a dû s'adapter trouver sa
méthode et du coup le résultat il a été
trouvé sur une note
sauf que là maintenant on a blank air
qui nous dit non l'école s'est très bien
passé et donc du coup les examens ils
vont se passer comme l'école très très
bien mais c'est complètement faux on va
se retrouver avec des personnes qui
auront juste pas étudié cette partie là
du programme quand ils seront devant la
copie est en fait s'il veut pas accepter
le contrôle continu qui est la solution
logique pour que tout le monde puisse
s'adapter c'est uniquement que s'il fait
ça il admet qu'il a raté sa politique
sur l'école et sur son adaptation à la
crise sanitaire et entre les gouttes
jean michel blanquer
et la vérité il ya les jeunes et nous on
en souffre et c'est pour ça qu'on est
tous là et les 91 % à lui dire mais va
mettre le pied dans une salle de classe
et mais nous le contrôle continu
alors il faut qu'il faudrait installer
une marée là